[Música]
el primer ministro japonés shinzo abe
anunció su dimisión al cargo por motivos
de salud
en 2007 el político también tuvo que
renunciar por una colitis ulcerosa
crónica avn o precisó en la rueda de
prensa la fecha en la que abandonara el
gobierno
finalizó la convención nacional
republicana en eeuu el presidente de
donald trump centró su discurso en
ataques a joe biden y lo llamó el
destructor de la grandeza estadounidense
posteriormente aceptó la nominación a la
presidencia mientras que afuera de la
casa blanca se realizaba una protesta
antigubernamental
y seguimos con nuestra serie de los
adolescentes durante esta pandemia de
coronavirus o nos vamos hasta argentina
donde conoceremos la historia de lucía
ella nos cuenta como la pandemia del
cuarto las experiencias de su último año
de secundaria algo que los adolescentes
esperan con muchas ansias
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si raúl blanco un
gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo con la renuncia del primer
ministro japonés shinzo abe por razones
de salud lo que abre un periodo de
consultas que terminará con las próximas
semanas con la elección de su sustituto
de 65 años señaló que la colitis
ulcerosa crónica que le obligó a dimitir
en su primer mandato lo está afectando
nuevamente y el tratamiento que debe
recibir exige una revisión continua y
vigilada el mandatario no precisó cuándo
dejará el cargo ni tampoco quién será su
sucesor veamos el informe que ha
preparado matías arráez
el pueblo japonés tuvo este viernes un
día hábil sin duda de renuncia por
segunda vez a su cargo de primer
ministro a sus 65 años al mandatario
nipón explicó que estaba sufriendo un
retorno de su antigua enfermedad crónica
que ya le había obligado a renunciar en
2007 un año después de haber sido
elegido por primera vez
pero dadas mis enfermedades y mis
tratamientos
andrade fueron acá y mi imperfecto
estado de salud
ellas han dado además coto no puedo
permitir que estas condiciones
comprometan mis decisiones políticas o
mis resultados
otra ahora que no puedo cumplir con el
mandato y la confianza de la gente que
vende una zanahoria
he decidido dejar el cargo de primer
ministro a la luz de de vuelta en el
cargo desde hace casi ocho años ave
apareció visiblemente conmovido en el
ministro también dijo que estaba
profundamente apenado con el pueblo
japonés por haber dejado su puesto un
año antes de lo previsto y en medio de
la crisis de coronavirus foto que cree
eso estoy sorprendido parecía muy
cansado pero no pensé que renunciaría
desearía que pudiera trabajar más duro y
quedarse como primer ministro un poco
más
el mandatario se negó este viernes a
expresar públicamente su preferencia por
un sucesor diciendo que todas las
personas cuyos nombres circulan son
personas muy capaces hasta que se
designe el próximo primer ministro
japonés a ver aseguró que se mantendrá
firme en el cargo
y de japón nos vamos a eeuu donde el
presidente de donald trump pronunció
anoche su discurso final en la
convención nacional del partido
republicano en el que atacó al candidato
demócrata joe biden afirmando que no es
el salvador del alma de eeuu sino el
destructor y prometió que en su segundo
mandato creerá más empleos que nunca
para hablar de lo que ocurrió anoche
tanto dentro y afuera de la casa blanca
quiero saludar en este momento a nuestra
corresponsal en washington dice diana
castañeda diana muy buen día
buen día pues básicamente el presidente
donald trump se mostró en esta cerca de
una hora que duró su discurso como el
único líder que puede restaurar el orden
en la nación después de muchas protestas
que hemos visto durante todo este año en
búsqueda de justicia racial que reclaman
cientos de ciudadanos pero también
organizaciones que defienden los
derechos civiles y fueron estas mismas
protestas las que se registraron en
frente de la casa blanca justo cuando el
mandatario daba su discurso en el ala
sur en los jardines exteriores la gente
los manifestantes gritaban pence y trump
fuera ya y sin justicia no hay paz estas
son otras manifestaciones que también se
esperan se registren el día de hoy pero
el mandatario también se mostró en su
discurso como el único que puede llevar
a un crecimiento económico sostenido en
los eeuu con su propuesta de crear 10
millones de trabajos en 10 meses el tema
también más esperado era el manejo que
iba a dar sobre en la pandemia y el
mandatario decidió
y no hablar de cifras por ejemplo los 20
millones de personas que se encuentran
sin empleo más de 170 mil personas que
han perdido la vida durante la pandemia
y se centró en prometer una vacuna para
final de año y para que todo vuelva a la
normalidad en 2021 con reapertura de
escuelas y de negocios también junto a
su mensaje del discurso se podía ver
como los cerca de 1500 asistentes que
fueron a la casa blanca rompieron las
normas del distrito de columbia ya que
no se podían registrar aglomeraciones de
más de 50 personas y finalmente el
mandatario habló en términos acerca de
su contrincante críticas hacia bailén
asegurando que sino eeuu se enfrentaría
socialismo anarquía comunismo lo que
contrasta con las expresiones que vimos
por parte de la convención demócrata
como por ejemplo racismo en los eeuu al
igual que temor y miedo así que los dos
digamos partidos apelaron más al miedo
de los votantes y veremos finalmente en
noviembre 3 y en las urnas cuál de estos
dos mensajes llegó a los votantes diana
gracias por la información seguimos en
eeuu ahora quiero saludar a vanessa
porras analista política y directora del
center for clover procter señora porras
gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
francés 24 con la culminación de estas
dos convenciones tanto en la republicana
como la demócrata en su opinión cuál fue
la más acertada y cuál de las dos tuvo
más receptividad por parte de los
estadounidenses
creo que la convención republicana pues
se dedicó a resaltar lo peligroso que ha
sido el peligroso que ha sido el
socialismo por ejemplo latinoamérica lo
peligroso que sería para eeuu llegar a
tener este esto implantado en su país
hablaron de lo grave por ejemplo que
sería para ellos tener un presidente
como bailén que
está apoyado por personas como la humana
como bernie sanders como alessandra o
cortes por ejemplo quienes siguen
insistiendo en no juzgar y en ver con
buena cara el socialismo por ejemplo en
venezuela y que no tildan a nicolás
maduro como un dictador que es realmente
lo que es
resulta llamativo el desenlace que ha
tenido esta convención republicana que
concluyó en la noche con el discurso del
presidente trump y quien hizo un repaso
de los logros de su administración el
manejo habló del manejo de la crisis del
cobi y de los peligros ante la
posibilidad pues de que yo guayo bardem
tome esta presidencia y habló también de
de poder traerlas con las tropas a casa
de mejorar el sistema educativo de
reforzar las leyes migratorias de evitar
a toda costa la entrada de inmigrantes
ilegales creo que lo importante sería
que los estados unidos realmente retomé
el sendero de la libertad que han
marcado los padres fundadores de este
país
desde un camino de libertades económicas
el libre mercado de libertades
individuales y empezar a reducir el
tamaño del estado cosa que no ha pasado
durante esta administración que más bien
ha aumentado el gasto público en déficit
y en deuda señora porras que podemos ver
de ahora en adelante en las campañas
políticas de cara a estas elecciones de
noviembre
pues vamos a ver una pelea bastante
reñida vemos por ejemplo como en estados
como el estado de florida en donde
generalmente trump siempre lleva la
delantera pues tenemos que estar
encabezando las encuestas bailén pero
también creo que no podemos este creer
en los sondeos de las encuestas en las
elecciones pasadas por ejemplo iba
ganando este hillary clinton en este
estado y gracias a los resultados de los
colegios electorales pues vimos que el
ganador terminó siendo trump
señor o corras gracias por la
información y por estar aquí con
nosotros en francés 24 y nosotros
también continuamos haciéndole
seguimiento a las protestas en wisconsin
luego de que la policía balear a jake
blake los manifestantes se reunieron
anoche en el lugar donde se encuentran
los organismos gubernamentales y la
policía local colocó cordones para
bloquearlos las autoridades de que nos
adelantaron el toque de queda a las 19
horas y cerraron algunas carreteras
principales al área urbana en un intento
por evitar que estos manifestantes
ingresaran a la ciudad y que los locales
también salieran a las calles sin
embargo no se respetó este decreto por
su parte de la oficina de derechos
humanos de la onu dijo que las imágenes
del tiroteo de jake blake en el disco
ncn parecían mostrar que el oficial de
policía había usado fuerza excesiva que
probablemente era de naturaleza
discriminatoria eso lo dijo la oficina
de derechos humanos de las naciones
unidas
y a pesar que las cifras diarias de
contagio siguen altas en colombia su
capital bogotá puso fines del jueves a
la medida del confinamiento estricto la
alcaldía tomó esta decisión porque
considera que el nivel de contagio está
disminuyendo las restricciones también
se relajarán en todo el país a partir
del próximo primero de septiembre
el informe de lionel puse rey
en esta zona central de la capital
colombiana la vida parece haber vuelto a
la normalidad después de 5 meses de
confinamiento estricto los bogotanos
están autorizados a salir libremente a
la calle y los comercios han podido
retomar sus actividades
tenemos más movilidad y más posibilidad
de trabajar porque es que el comercio
estaba absolutamente quieto perdido
entonces ya podemos trabajar un poco más
un tercio de los más de 570.000
contagios del país han sido en bogotá la
alcaldesa claudia lópez anunció la
flexibilización de las medidas tras una
disminución del número de pacientes en
las unidades de cuidados intensivos en
las últimas semanas varios gremios
cayeron la reapertura de la economía a
pesar del miedo
hoy en esto el día con mucha gente mucho
tráfico de carros y mucha gente como si
la situación esto era normal cuando
realmente la pandemia la pandemia sigue
pero de todas maneras pues no trata de
estar aislado de las demás personas
conserva la distancia y pues tenemos que
salir como sea llevarle el pan de cada
día a la casa a pesar de la situación
que está tan dura tan difícil
con el aumento del número de personas en
la calle el temor de nuevos contagios
que presente en la mente de muchas
personas
es bastante irresponsable porque hay
muchísima gente y en este momento todos
estamos expuestos mira yo traigo 2
tapabocas y sin embargo realizamos el
cambio pero hay gente que lo utiliza
aquí entonces en realidad estamos
bastante expuestos que aunque deseamos
unas personas de 25 estamos en un rango
de aquí en este momento que seamos
jóvenes no quiere decir que no tengamos
no estemos expuestos para el contagio en
colombia la siguiente fase de apertura
está prevista para el próximo primero de
septiembre con el fin de las
restricciones de desplazamiento en todo
el país
la unióneuropea últimas sanciones contra
altos cargos de belarús por considerar
que se cometió fraude electoral la nueva
ronda de sanciones podría incluir al
presidente alexander lukashenko y la
tramitación de estas medidas llevará
todavía al menos una semana a la unión
europea está de acuerdo en imponer
sanciones hasta una veintena de altos
funcionarios de los rusos como
sospechosos del fraude electoral y por
la también la represión a los
manifestantes ayer fueron detenidas unas
180 personas en unas nuevas protestas
incluidos más de 20 periodistas
y seguimos con nuestra serie de informes
grabados y narrados por adolescentes
durante esta pandemia hoy conoceremos la
historia de lucía tuero de 17 años desde
argentina ella nos cuenta como la
pandemia del puerto las experiencias de
su último año de secundaria algo que los
adolescentes esperan con ansias durante
años un reportaje grabado por lucía bajo
la coordinación de nuestro corresponsal
natalio co soy
en marzo de este año empecé mi último
año en secundaria
fuimos la primera semana del colegio y
después decreto la 40 y no obligatoria
así que desde este momento hasta ahora
toda la cursada fue virtual fue un
cambio enorme porque todo el mundo
espera durante toda la secundaria el
último año con un montón de expectativas
y tuvimos que adaptarnos aceptar que no
nos iba a tocar vivir lo mismo ni de la
misma forma uno tiene que ser muy
consciente y estar muy agradecido de en
qué posición le tocó vivir todo esto por
suerte en mi familia conservaron sus
trabajos creo que esas cosas que antes
capaz pasaron desapercibidas o no les
dábamos el valor que de verdad se
merecen hoy hoy nos damos cuenta cuánto
las extrañamos y cosas super básicas
como ir a una plaza y tomar algo o
juntarme en una casa o salir a hacer
cualquier cosa yo creo que eso es una de
las cosas que más extraña puedes hacer
lo que te gusta con gente que querés yo
primero que importa
es que tenéis sobrante la cuarentena que
ya tengo varias actividades al canto
teatro y transmisión ahora
estoy haciendo un ejercicio ya semana
para hablar a la ventana para
promocionarme de energía
en este vídeo traté de mostrar una de
las citas que adquirimos estando en
cuarentena este vídeo surgió a partir de
mis clases de teatro obviamente hay días
que son más alegres a días que son más
tristes con menos energía con menos
ganas de hacer cosas en un día normal
podría hablar con personas que quiero
durante tres horas seguidas sin
aburrirme y hoy por hoy al estar todo el
día en mi casa o sin hacer cosas
diferentes siento que no hay tantos
temas de conversación eso no hay tanto
para contar lo primero que quiero hacer
una vez que termine esto es ver a toda
la gente que quiero que extraño un
montón quiero ir al cine adquirir el
teatro quiero salir tengo un montón de
cosas que quiero hacer con termine
a seguir informativa en france en ti 4
continua con nosotros
[Música]